hablemos primero de este caso que
conmueve al país y al mundo en general
sebastián no había podido superar la
depresión causada por esta enorme
violencia verdad
así es justamente y lamentablemente se
cumplió uno de los peores miedos que
teníamos como organización que busca
asistir a las víctimas para respetar o
no para que su familia que el abandono
del estado la indolencia del estado y
del gobierno que los atacó y los
abandonó a su suerte los empujará a
tomar la decisión de quitarse la vida
y esto es muy lamentable porque el caso
de patricio que ocurrió acá a más de dos
años atrás es paradigmático ya que por
parte del estado y por parte del
gobierno se sabía que él tenía una
depresión muy profunda que no fue
atendida a tiempo que no fue atendida
con la sistematicidad necesaria para
para que su caso tuviera un desenlace
diferente
ahora durante aquellas masivas
manifestaciones de las fuerzas dejaron
cientos de víctimas que perdieron como
decíamos previamente de forma parcial o
total sus ojos algo que causó muchísima
consternación y esto se dio además en
protestas en otros países del mundo por
qué crees que tantos manifestantes
sufren este tipo de lesiones oculares
bueno efectivamente en chile desde el
tee solamente desde el 18 octubre del
2019 de nuestro denominado estallido
social en adelante hay más de 500
personas que han sido víctimas de trauma
ocular por violencia estatal esto como
tú bien decías ha ocurrido en otros
países del mundo
y
luego durante este año también en
colombia con más de 100 casos de
víctimas de trauma ocular producto de la
represión indiscriminada en el contexto
del paro nacional en colombia ha pasado
en brasil en protestas contra
evolucionado nos ha pasado en perú y han
pasado también durante este año en en
bolivia todo esto tiene a la base a
nuestro parecer del uso del armamento de
impacto cinético para el control del
orden público y de muchedumbres que
utilizan las policías de toda nuestra
región y gran parte del mundo
este armamento que es un arma no está
pensado en la guerra pero que utiliza
munición denominada menos letal es la
que está detrás y es la protagonista de
cientos de lesiones oculares alrededor
de todo el mundo en francia también en
españa' en barcelona también ha habido
casos de trauma ocular por violencia
estatal